your brothers and sisters in Islam net
from Norway are establishing a Masid a
DA Center this Center this Masid this
educational institution will act like a
beacon of light calling the Muslims in
Norway back to the essence of Islam so
give generously and Allah will give you
even more I just wanted to mention this
verse because I for me it's just get the
elephant out of the room and then we can
move on um sometimes it's just replaced
by a slightly smaller El elephant
well smaller elephant is better than
nothing um what I was going to say is
that you know it didn't land well with a
lot of the Muslim Community yeah and I
think the reason why is that it was seen
as condescending it was seen as um kind
of patronizing that what was your
intention with this video exactly
to start a dialogue stupidly and badly
because that's how you have to start
them you know we talked already about
the idea of Tolerance and I'm actually
not here to be tolerant
you know because tolerance sort of
presumes that I know what I'm doing and
you guys don't but I'll put up with you
anyways and uh see I don't actually
think I know what I'm doing exactly and
so I think well you might have something
to teach me and so it's not so much
tolerance as I would say hopefully
something approximating an expression of
reasonable humility which is well first
of of all we we occupy the same space
And as far as I'm concerned it'd be
better if we got along and we've all had
our own Revelations you know personally
and and let's say socially and we don't
know how to integrate those Revelations
and that's rough that's hard um and so
I'm here to listen and the message was
Preposterous in some sense although not
much more so than the message I made to
Christians which I wouldn't say say was
exactly
flattering
and uh you know I thought it would
probably ruffle some feathers but
but I thought it might also initiate a
dialogue or at least further it and that
has happened you know I mean certainly
there were many people who were
irritated at me and thought that I was
being condescending and I wasn't trying
to be because I I do have a lot of
people who are paying attention to my
lectures course around the world on the
Islamic side which is quite surprising
to me especially with regard to the
attention that's been given to the
biblical lectures and I don't take any
of that for granted and I wasn't trying
to either capitalize on it or or uh
interfere with it I was trying to do the
next stupid thing that might move things
forward a bit and that's actually it's
actually worked I would say well first
of all I am here and I know that's not a
direct consequence of that message but
at least it didn't break it and there
have been many other Muslim groups
who've reached out to me in a serious
way at least in part because of that and
so I think we have to understand that
we're going to stumble into each other a
fair bit if we actually try to talk
because of all the elephants and the
snakes that are lurking under the carpet
and I think it's a very good thing to
get them out in the open yeah I I'm a
very agreeable person really as it turns
out yes I know it's to my to my
detriment but um I would I wouldn't have
guessed to be honest that you're very
agreeable yes it's it's one of my major
character flaws but um I don't like
Conflict at all and but the reason I I
would say I'm prone to engage in it is
because
sometimes
what's under the carpet needs to be
revealed because it's going to cause a
lot of trouble if it just sits there and
bruise or Broods it multiplies and so it
is one of the advantages of disagreeable
people having them around because they
will haul things up for inspection that
everyone else might um be loathed to
confront you know the downside is well
you might do that too often you know and
that's a hard thing to get right so I'm
not here in a spirit of Tolerance I'm
here in a spirit of ignorance and I'm
hoping see the other thing I I've been
thinking through and you guys can tell
me what you think about this is it seems
that in the situation we're in now sort
of GL globally speaking that it would be
useful for people of religious Faith
to note that there are other people of
religious Faith with whom they have much
in common one of them being religious
faith and that they are also confronting
as people of religious Faith a world
that is attempting to let's say shake
itself free of that and so it isn't
exactly obvious to me that it's a great
time for people of religious faith to
concentrate on their differences given
that there are perhaps more important
elephants to address let's say or fish
to fry and so I've been trying to I'm
very ignorant about the Islamic
tradition um and I'm trying to rectify
that it's very difficult to step outside
your own culture and to really
understand someone else's and so and I'm
under no Illusions I hope about the
degree of understanding that I've
managed but I have tried to understand
what we might share in common and that's
crucial and so certainly one of the
ideas that we all share in common on the
religious front let's say is that there
is an ultimate unity that should be
placed Above All Else and so that's part
of the Great monotheistic tradition and
I'm going to speak mostly as a
psychologist rather than as say an
advocate of the Christian tradition
because I it is obvious to me that I let
me kind of push back back a little bit
on that point because you're an
individual like obviously in your news
book you you're talking very um
categorically about precision and I
would say you're an individual that is
very precise you're categorized like if
I was to say anything I would say that
you're individual that scrupulously
meticulous in exactitude and I don't
know meticulousness or whatever yeah so
you speak and you think about what
you're going to say before you say it
that's what you're known for in fact if
someone says something which is uh kind
of off the market a little bit you pull
them up for it right and you well
usually cuz I do understand it then yeah
for example like the Kathy Newman
interview like the assumptions and the
questioning that she had she had when
she was questioning you pulled her up on
it and that's why it became so uh
popular the discussion was so popular
and you're clinical psychologist so what
I was going to say is this I for example
if I were to make a video right I say
this a message to the you know to White
Canadians or something yeah and I said
you know it's hard to talk to them I say
look you know um tentatively why don't
you reach out to some Russians you know
or you know heaven forbid you know reach
out to black Africans or First Nation
people you know whatever it may be what
you how do you think the community of
why Canadians let's say for the sake of
argument will react to that kind of
message well if it was you yeah well
you're pretty disagreeable so you'd
probably get bit back a lot yeah but
exactly I don't I don't it's hard to say
until you do it you know I mean I have
reached out to other communities let's
say I did an interview with a friend of
mine who's a Native American Carver who
lives on the West Coast Po and you know
I'm not very happy with the narrative
that's being promoted in Canada which is
that the European
um settlement of Canada is best viewed
as genocidal Colonial and having said
that my friend this Carver was in a
residential school in Canada and the
residential schools were put forward by
the government um in an attempt and
other institutions in an attempt to
separate the indigenous children from
their families and then socialize them
rapidly according to European norms and
there was some positive motivation for
that and sometimes that helped and work
but one of the things that did happen
was that some schools were let's say
invaded by people of a pronounced
pedophilic and and sadistic bent and my
friend ended up in one of those schools
and his life was so Dreadful that you
can't even hear about it without without
without serious emotional damage and so
you know I went forward with that
discussion and it was very contentious
but it went very well and it it it told
a story that was true and needed to be
told yeah and so you know you step into
foreign territory at your peril that's
for sure but you know and it was
relatively difficult for me to arrange
for this to be a possibility of course
and and but my my thought again because
I'm trying to look for what we have to
offer each other rather than what
divides us I thought it was worthwhile
let me push back again once once again
on this point so for example it's not
always what you say sometimes it can be
what you don't say so for instance I
think you've become somewhat of an
emblem of Western Civilization right in
terms of you're an INT help us no you
have and I also push back on the point
that this is a foreign culture because I
think that Islam and you've mentioned
this in electure as well that Islam has
now become part of like you know Western
culture yeah well that's the open
question as as we noted in the
introductory marks it's like well are is
Islam part of the West we're kind of
having the same discussion about Russia
in some real sense and that's really
going well at the moment yeah so there's
that part but what I would say is that
you know if there there is a bloody
history of Western colonialism and
that's almost undeniable like for
example look at Algeria for instance
Algeria when it was annexed by France
there's no dispute in there's no dispute
in what happened there so the is like
I'm giving you one example of many this
Spanish colonialism of Latin America for
example um there are things that
happened and it's I'm not saying that's
not things that happened on only just on
the Western Front uh there are things
that happen on the Muslim front as well
of course this is true yeah no doubt
about it right no I'm not going to stand
here and you know defend the MU who came
and were very intolerant to Jews and
Christians and kick them out of their
homes and stuff like that who existed in
Spain as well in fact so the point is I
feel like I don't know as a psychologist
I think my question would be to you
don't you think is it of any benefit to
to be concessionary in this regard like
to start off a discussion by saying like
we know um that these are things that
could cause resentment yes the because
like for example I know a lot of
Algerian people and this is very clear
in their historical memory yes and the
the accusation will be that the West
have Colonial Amnesia here they don't
they are not taking into account what
they've done I'll be honest with you
well they don't don't even know how well
okay you see what I'm yeah well
absolutely I mean look here here's how I
would address that psychologically
um in in many of the mythological
stories that I've read There is the
motif of the evil uncle and so for
example in in the ancient Egyptian
cosmology
um the the there were two there were
four deities four Central deities
although a host of associated deities
and one of them was Osiris who is the
deity of the state that might be a good
way of thinking about it and he had an
evil Brothers Seth who was always
conspiring in the background to
overthrow the state and to establish his
own rule say based on Power and the
Egyptians this is thousands of years ago
had figured out by that point because
their society was quite large that there
was something in the social structure
itself that posed a threat to the
structure and that was the tendency for
the structure and its leaders to become
willfully blind and for conspiratorial
powers or patterns that would use res
resentment and the desire for power to
overthrow that and they thought of
Osiris as willfully blind and Seth as an
eternal
e
for